President Trump is taking no holiday
from his Twitter habit tonight the
president is continuing his criticism of
the federal judiciary in general and
Supreme Court Chief Justice John Roberts
in particular it comes on a Thanksgiving
holiday when the president expressed his
thanks to the troops while staying close
to home
correspondent Kevin corks at the
president's Florida Resort in West Palm
Beach tonight good evening Kevin evening
my good to be with you and Happy
Thanksgiving the president spending this
Thanksgiving evening 2018 having a
little Thanksgiving dinner and spending
time with his family something that he
began the day by thanking those who were
not quite as lucky it's a time-honored
Thanksgiving tradition for the
commander-in-chief extending the
gratitude of the American people to
those who serve and protect President
Trump doing so today both in person and
by phone I want to express our profound
gratitude for the extraordinary
sacrifices you make to defend our nation
while you're away from your families and
loved ones it was a visible outpouring
of appreciation from mr. Trump but still
in stark contrast to his predecessors
President Bush paid a surprise visit to
US troops in Iraq over the Thanksgiving
holiday in 2003 President Obama met with
troops both in 2010 and again in 2014
mr. Trump's comparative absence has
drawn sharp criticism from some even
sparking speculation that he simply
doesn't want to go
defense secretary Jim mattis rejected
that notion adding that security is
always a concern the president's the
commander in chief and he decides where
he needs to go there are times I don't
want him in certain locations while the
president did hint today as well as
earlier in the week that he does intend
to visit American troops abroad there
was no ambiguity about his feelings on
border security saying again today that
he'd authorized American troops on the
us-mexico border to use lethal force if
necessary against an approaching group
of migrants while also threatening to
close the quotes hole border in quote if
it means protecting American safety and
sovereignty I've given the okay they
have to hope they don't have to but you
know you're dealing with a minimum of
500 serious criminals so I'm not gonna
let the military be taken advantage of I
have no choice
the president was also active on Twitter
this Thanksgiving day including a pair
of missives aimed at Supreme Court Chief
Justice John Roberts and the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals with which the
administration has sparred over a number
of they feel politically motivated legal
challenges to the Trump agenda including
border security and Asylum policies I
know that Chief Justice Roberts John
Roberts has been speaking a little bit
about it I think we have to use some
common sense it's nice Ninth Circuit
everybody knows it it's totally out of
control it's a disgrace frankly and
essentially they're legislating they're
saying what to do Mike it's important to
point this out there are plenty of
reasons frankly to believe that the
president will in fact follow through on
his threat to shut down the quote hole
border you may recall it was actually
back on Monday when the port of entry at
San Ysidro was shut down first
several hours amid security concerns
Mike Kevin quark with the president of
West Palm Beach Florida
Kevin many thanks